good morning believe nation today's
message is work hard over to you Nadia
Comaneci you know when well I used to
say today we do five routines on diamond
I used to do seven so I could do more
than he was asking to uh I I don't mind
working hard I don't complain that I
work hard I think that you have to work
hard to get to that level I I think that
I'm not looking for the easy way to do
things and I'm proud about that a lot of
entrepreneurs underestimate how much
work it is to run a business right for
those of you who've already started you
know what I'm talking about and for
those of you who haven't started yet you
may think it's hard but once you get
into it you realize it's ten times
harder than your worst-case scenario
it's hard it's one of the hardest things
you ever going to do and you need to
work for it the key thing though is one
that you you love it because the only
way you're going to deal with all the
crap and all the hard work and push
through all the barriers that are going
to come out is that you love what you're
doing and the second thing is that you
are consistent a lot of people will work
hard for three months and then give up
right and they've run out of money have
to go back and get a job where the key
thing is that you are doing work
consistently every single day they get
closer to your dreams we overestimate
what we can do in a short amount of time
but we underestimate what we can do in a
longer period of time so make sure that
you are consistent and you work hard
every single day that you watch the
video series you leave the comment that
you make progress on your business
because that's how to the consistent
action you're going to be able to
accomplish your dreams believe so my
question of the day today is I want to
know how hard it is for you as an
entrepreneur compared to your
expectations before you got in how hard
did you think it was going to be
compared to how hard is it actually
leave it in the comments below I'm
really curious to find out thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and i'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events presser
expreso give me go